"It's too dangerous.
I have to go alone."
Those are the words Daisy Ridley's Rey utters
in the brand-new footage from Star Wars: The
Rise of Skywalker shown at 2019's D23 Expo.
Lucasfilm took the stage on Saturday during
the hotly anticipated Walt Disney Studios
presentation to unveil fresh footage from
the Star Wars saga-ending The Rise of Skywalker.
Director J.J. Abrams explained that the creative
team is working hard on putting the finishing
touches on the film and is tinkering away
at a new trailer to reveal ahead of the movie's
December 20 release date.
But he didn't want to leave the Star Wars
fans in attendance hanging.
So, he, his Lucasfilm partners, and The Rise
of Skywalker cast gifted the world with a
stellar sizzle reel featuring shots from the
flick.
The footage reportedly received a standing
ovation.
The Hollywood Reporter had the breakdown of
the footage, which shows a sizable fleet of
Star Destroyers clustered in the sky, Rey
and Kylo Ren battling atop a sunken ship in
the ocean, and a first look at Keri Russell's
character Zorri Bliss in action — a Boba
Fett-style bounty hunter type whom Russell
describes as, quote, "very cool and a little
bit shady … kind of a criminal."
She's also apparently an old friend of Poe
Dameron's.
The new Rise of Skywalker footage ended with
the most jaw-dropping shot of all: Rey is
seen cloaked in a dark hood and holding a
dual-bladed lightsaber that's glowing red.
"That lightsaber… it belongs to me."
This suggests that Rey, who struggled with
understanding and channeling the Force in
The Last Jedi, may give into temptation and
turn to the dark side in The Rise of Skywalker.
C'mon, a red saber with two blades?
A black hood over her head?
Rey's giving serious dark side vibes in the
new footage, and it's already sending fans
into a spiral of speculation - with many theorizing
that the get-up she sports in the new footage
may be her response to discovering her true
parentage, which has always been a hot point
of discussion amongst fans.
If The Rise of Skywalker reveals that Rey
is a descendant of a prominent dark-sider
- like, say, Emperor Palpatine - she certainly
couldn't be blamed for having an existential
crisis.
On the other hand, maybe she's wearing a creepy
hood and wielding a new lightsaber because
she's trying to infiltrate the First Order
as part of a Resistance mission.
That seems more likely than Rey going mad,
but hey, anything goes in the Star Wars universe.
Unfortunately, The Rise of Skywalker sizzle
reel wasn't immediately made available online.
The silver lining is that something else related
to the movie is: a badass new poster.
Lucasfilm unveiled the one-sheet at the Walt
Disney Studios presentation on Saturday, giving
fans a glimpse at the tone and aesthetic of
the upcoming film.
Aside from Palpatine's tell-tale cackle in
the first Rise of Skywalker teaser, It's one
of the first confirmations that the one-time
Emperor of the galaxy will be playing a role
in Episode 9.
These reveals should tide fans over until
Lucasfilm drops the second trailer for The
Rise of Skywalker, and definitely serve to
boost hype for the flick that will supposedly
cap off the nine-movie Skywalker saga.
The Star Wars franchise will, of course, live
on after The Rise of Skywalker with new movies
from Last Jedi director Rian Johnson, and
Game of Thrones creators David Benioff and
D.B. Weiss.
There's also the three live-action Star Wars
TV series coming to the Disney+ streaming
platform: The Mandalorian, a Rogue One prequel
centered on Diego Luna's character Cassian
Andor, and the recently announced Obi-Wan
Kenobi show.
"Hello there."
Still, The Rise of Skywalker marks the end
of an important era, and will apparently be
the last Star Wars film for a while, as the
franchise is taking a hiatus from feature
films after its release.
The hope is that The Rise of Skywalker will
be so epic that fans completely forget there
won't be a new Star Wars movie hitting the
big screen for some time.
Based on this footage description, the new
poster, and the action-packed first trailer,
that goal should be easily achieved.
The end is nigh, and the saga is sure to go
out with a bang when Episode 9 lands in theaters
on December 20.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Star Wars
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.